Singo Muse sing of the righteous wrath
of me forsooth I am mightily outraged
that Hollywood got clogged up yon
multiplex with a glut of Greek demigods
the new Brett Ratner film hercules
follows hot on the packs of Renny
Harlin's legend of hercules from january
ostensibly upgrading the legend with a
healthy dose of dwayne the rock johnson
and that's just the first level of the
hellenic hell that we're all being
forced to endure every time you turn
around another sword and sandal and CG
extravaganza springs from the empty head
of a studio exam oh that bombastic
remake of clash of the titans besmirches
the holy legacy of Harryhausen peace be
upon i feel like i'm being force fed a
diet of cinematic souvlaki and I crave
different cuisines if movie moguls want
to pillage world religions for
time-tested storylines they should look
beyond the Peloponnesian Peninsula where
is the movie about Bobby Bobby the snake
deity of the bin binga people of
northern Australia and why no
blockbuster about the Hawaiian shark God
comma Holly enough with the movies based
on homer and Apollonius of roads I want
to see movies based on the storytelling
style of West African gris ons I want to
see TV serials like the ones in India
that are based on ancient Hindu epics
hundreds of spellbinding episodes about
the journey of Rama or the Kurukshetra
war and why are Mesopotamian myths
relegated to bad guy roles in
ghostbusters Oh go to the destroyer make
me your key master and I will force
filmmakers to devote entire trilogy's to
your memorable deeds during the
rectification of the Waldron aye and the
third reconciliation of the last of the
McKettrick supplicants I event
vince clortho keymaster of gozer Vulcans
he'll draw our Lord of the civilian are
you the gatekeeper I can't even talk
about the crummy film versions of the
percy jackson books let me know what you
thought of those mythological
monstrosities in the comments and
subscribe to the wired channel